this guy's
right here about right here
[Music]
so uh Rick Ross said that he would never
ride in a Tesla because he fears the
self-driving car could take him to the
authorities against his will that's true
like like she's gonna be in a dance
where are we going you are you have a
bond you have a bond on you that's the
funniest and most gangster [__] I've
ever heard that is really funny that's
like if you imagine like El Chapo says
some [__] like that it's but it's funny
but it's also like those are problems I
never thought about it's also funny that
Rick Ross thinks she's the kind of
person that would have to be actually
physically evading police capture uh
obviously it's not just constantly
evading but also like let's say if um he
was a witness or something or if he
heard something you know what I mean so
like you know the people the police need
to bring him in and subpoena him in for
something because a lot of rappers are
getting arrested right now that's so
funny dude so he says he's never ridden
in the Tesla before oh he doesn't even
ride in one no so for Uber shows up in
the Tesla he's like nah the next one
dude all the time by the way the door's
gonna walk
he did also he said he also believes
that cars would be able to repossess
themselves in the future I believe that
that's a that's a highly smart utility
you didn't pay your bill and then the
Tesla just bounces why not yeah that's
that's uh if you're doing a subscription
model for a car which I think will
happen because everything's going there
it'll be wild and then a second
everyone's in these types of cars then
it's like dude that's that's it good
thing all my cars are from the 1980s
yeah
so now then there's gonna be some
[__] law in like you know a decade or
so that says you have to get rid of
these like you know [__] pollutant
type vehicles or whatever and you just
gotta move to a state or you could
grandfather those things like where man
I don't know why there's such a state
yeah
is there any other states one of my
neighbors is getting all of his cars uh
re-registered I think in Montana or
something yeah there's this Montana
loophole uh where the tax is different
and you don't pay anything loophole was
out on the back of a Chinese news did
you guys know in Vegas you apparently
have to pay like a portion of what the
vehicle is worth every year what yeah
the registration's expensive in Vegas if
you have like a like I have a buddy with
a Tesla yeah and he had to pay like
three grand what for registration
registration because it's like a portion
of what it's worth or whatever the [__]
but every year yeah my last registration
there's a grand yeah I paid a grand for
a which car my truck the Tacoma yeah a
grand is nuts if it's yearly that's
pretty but they said that that's what
are you doing I just made 140. well when
I was at the DMV they're they're saying
that like you know how different states
take taxes in different ways that's one
of the ways that Nevada does do it so
it's like you get no income tax but you
you're you're slam you hard the DMV fees
and all that shit's High because usually
it's how new the car is
yeah I think that's involved I think
it's evolved because GEOS Tesla was like
400 bucks or something he just said he
paid a thousand dollars first mine's a
2021 2021 yeah
I think the Montana thing is getting
cracked down on because too many people
make content about it they all know yeah
and now like when they catch you with
Montana plates and Cali then they just
like send you to the freaking thing like
they'll just write you up yeah so the
loophole one more time is when you like
the DB dudes that buy Lambos and then
they'll register it a month they'll like
have an LLC that's located in Montana or
some [__] and then they'll just register
it to that business and they don't pay
tax on it my my neighbor was telling me
this is like probably one of the most
bosses should ever heard anybody say but
he's told me he has awesome cars Montana
something about [__] businesses
Delaware or something about something in
Wyoming and he goes uh oh nothing and
control everything and I was like
is he Scarface bro Delaware is one of
like the hotbeds for everyone like
registering their company yeah yeah I
think Chase is registered in television
but nobody [__] lives there works
there yeah but he was like he's like I'm
unsuitable what are you gonna get a
penny and I'm like damn that's [__]
question to be unsuitable that's a nice
place that's pretty gangster but that's
a lot of work if I'm only making like 50
Grand a year you know like
yeah that's the reason why guys do that
for the Montana thing because they're
buying cars that are like 400 Grand so
when you imagine the amount of tax
you're saving but it's not it's not
practical for someone's buying a Prius
here he also says he's ungoogleable too
because of the way everything's set up
he's anti-seo yeah yeah you can't go in
you shouldn't walk around saying you're
unsuitable and ungoogable you're asking
you to be Googled I think he wants to be
tested to be honest people are going to
start googling your [__] Target on
your back my boy have you Googled it
after you talked to him no I'm lazy
that's a lot of work though shoot that's
true you'll never get tested I I know I
just make sure I spend everything so
then if they sue me I'm bankrupt I just
imagine that the people who are truly
unsuitable and ungoogleable have never
mentioned it once
I'm unsuitable and on Google I'd be
going this motherfucker's house with
slippers on and I'd Ajax those things
I'd be Slip Sliding all over his [__]
and I'm like that's a lawsuit that's a
lawsuit
my I crack my elbow that's a lawsuit I
don't even own this house yeah exactly
that's true damn that is good damn dude
I'd be there I'd be like I [__] your
wife dude your wife bro [__] her up
the butt too and she loved it especially
from me she loved it this guy's
right here [__] right here
are you Incorporated in Nevada [__]
what if he's not even married to her
because he doesn't even own anything
cool man he's like I married her under
an LLC and he [__] caught oh okay
yeah
our corporations got married he's like I
married her in a trust no I murdered her
likeness but not her damn protected dude
that's like the idea of you doing that
to someone and them just being like Oh
Steve Green you're so dead man
don't say you're not suitable or not
googleable if you don't want me to [__]
it it's like it's like [__] with
someone outside of the detention door
and you're just like
almost do you want to get up without
Steve Green pushing all my buttons again
I like the scenario that somebody's like
I'm unsuitable so Steve's like I'm gonna
go [__] his wife
alleged that he did oh I'm telling you
because like that's one of the biggest
ways you get some you can get sued that
happens to athletes all the time when
you [__] someone's wife no oh get under
their skin in multiple ways no like you
get under their skin like if you're a
fighter and you're at a bar everyone's
gonna be talking [__] to you you could
sue them NFL players NBA players they
all want an assault charge because it's
a big time payday little settlement
right yeah so I like how they never
think about like what if it goes
backfires so hard that you die
like they don't think about that maybe
they already got nothing to lose
yeah true yeah
or they did it five times already they
know how far it goes but my favorite
[__] is when they catch on a dash cam
when the car comes up and they go oh oh
and then they hit the car oh [__] that
is really nice it's always like China
and Russia it's the best and it's always
like on a Tesla or something like that
it has cameras right and then they see
the camera they just keep walking well
it's because they know it's a nice car
like this will be a nice payday but it's
like oh that's a little risky though
because they they might have the kamis
up that's that's just crazy when when uh
the idea that if somebody has a lot of
money then they have to pay you a lot of
money for something they did but if some
dude's rolling around broke with no
insurance you can [__] anything up and
there's nothing and everyone feels like
yeah [__] 50 of the car accident out
here in La yeah they just hit you and go
off because nobody's got insurance and
[__] exactly that's just crazy in L.A
you're just like hey hey yeah [__] it I
don't care it's a little scratch I don't
give a [__] all right see you later I've
been hit by a Mercedes and they did that
they did a driving run like when we
exited off the 60 over here and then uh
you know how like some people if they
see the car move out of the peripheral
vision they think they're going but it
was one of those right I was like I came
out I'm like oh [__] oops I guess I
can't and then when I stepped on the
brakes they hit me I'm like oh [__] what
the [__] like as soon as I got out
they're like oh dude did I hit your car
I'm like yeah maybe just pull over he
goes okay he just [__] bounced and I
was like oh well that's funny yeah it
was in a Mercedes yeah but you also have
a tank so my my car broke his headlights
I don't I didn't he didn't get out to
look at his damages so nothing really
happened to my car but he ran away he
ran because I think he thought he was so
it was worse for him it was worse but he
so weird well it would have been his
fault anyway where in Glendale did this
happen and how Armenian was he oh that's
true it was Mexican Armenian I think
you know dude's like a nice one because
what if it's not even his car and all
that [__] he didn't want to deal with it
oh maybe yeah or could have been a
rental first of all they drive Beamers
yeah that's true but hey Mercedes
doesn't mean nothing now because that's
the choice car of like every criminal
right now that's true it's so weird it's
always like a Mercedes that these like
they're rolling up in the Mercedes and
then just dropping drugs yeah yeah it's
kind of a it's kind of a sick branding
change for Mercedes oh God it's a car
for criminals yeah yeah well isn't that
like they did like a survey and it said
that like more more people of low income
that can't afford mercedes-owned
Mercedes
yeah it doesn't surprise them the
leasing options are just so great and
flexible exactly
the same as like regular car leasing
it's almost predatory yeah it's
strange I missed it yeah it is all right
because like those those car dealerships
are always trying to get like the LA hot
people that have like [__] followers
and influencers and [__] to have those
cars but then to like not own them
necessarily because they're just trying
to get other people to buy them I like
the status thing yeah it's like when
influencers get caught in like some
fuselage and like on a private jet I'm
gonna go later
without wheels like hanging out
it's a set yeah it's a set that's the
sucky thing about like like style you
know like rent to own rims and tires
yeah that business model how it's
preying on people that absolutely can't
afford it but it's so important to have
that image yeah that's kind of sad
that's hella sad it's like they like
getting put rims repoed but the funniest
thing to me is like the epitome of class
for them yeah Forgiatos it's like that's
the top yeah I just don't I just don't
get people who got a floss all the time
bro don't get it
save your money aim higher
you are closing right now I'm flossing
hard
[Music]